hey guys Peter Brown here with the game
spot news update Xbox one sales are up
in the UK making Microsoft's console the
top seller of the last week Microsoft is
heavily promoting FIFA 15 for the Xbox
one which is pushed hardware sales by
one hundred and fifty five percent
week-over-week in the UK television
commercials advertise the game
specifically for the Xbox one despite it
being a multi-platform game FIFA 15
which accounted for an extraordinary
eighty percent of all game sales last
week in the UK also boosted playstation
4 sales by about eighty percent the Xbox
one has recently received a 20-pound
price drop as part of the limited time
promotion which could have also aided
the console sales another news Xbox one
is also making headlines today for
launching in China being the first
console to be released there since they
were banned in the year 2000 the ban was
lifted last year it is unknown how the
consoles selling but according to some
studies there are more potential gamers
in China than the total population of
the United States head on over to
gamespot com / news for more xbox one
updates